ouille at il le plus d'attentats
terroristes ottawa le 22 octobre 2014
hommes armés dessus une personne dans
une attaque terroriste
le même jour à bagdad une voiture piégée
explose et tue 35 personnes depuis la
chute de saddam hussein il ya douze ans
en irak
les actes terroristes font partie du
quotidien les attaques ont d'abord viser
les troupes américaines puis la
population civile
c'est dans ce pays il ya eu le plus
d'actes terroristes entre 2003 et 2013
en moyenne il s'en est produit trois
pages au les tensions religieuses et
ethniques sont omniprésentes en irak la
police et l'armée ont du mal à contrôler
le pays entre 2003 et 2013 aux états
unis selon le global terrorism database
38 personnes ont été tuées lors
d'attentats terroristes pour la même
période en irak 35 1997 personnes ont
été tuées par des terroristes en fait 60
% des personnes tuées dans un attentat
terroriste l'ont été dans trois pays
l'irak l'afghanistan et le pakistan
64 1630 mans incluant les auteurs